êtes vous d'accord avec le mouvement
balances ton corps on a marre il a guéri
et féministe étudiante de 22 ans a eu
ses partiels architecture là cette
semaine elle m'a dit donc est là elle
avoue j'espère que ça va bien se passer
pour vous vous avez publié en juillet
dernier la vidéo où on vous voit vous
faire frapper au visage par un homme
après qui vous est harcelée donc c'est
une vidéo qui a beaucoup tourné qui a
beaucoup choqué on va la voir dans un
instant merci d'être avec notre cas de
marie merci jeu très dur gras et je suis
extrêmement heureux également d'avoir
elisabeth lévy directrice de la
rédaction de causeur voilà voilà causeur
voilà quel mac elle m'a gentiment offert
merci beaucoup elisabeth lévy il est là
merci à vous a demandé ça fait longtemps
qu'on vous demande un sur les missions
et merci d'avoir répondu présentes ce
soir alors les images de votre vidéo
pour avoir elles ont été vues 2,4
millions de fois alors juste avant qu'on
voit ces images des images de mari êtes
vous d'accord avec le mouvement balances
ton corps y en a deux qui disent non on
vous demande vous pose la question si
eric revel oui moi je suis absolument
d'accord avec ce hashtag serait comme
lire un petit truc shirin c'est que
parmi les acheteurs qui ont été
sélectionnés y en a beaucoup pour
lesquelles j'aurais pu également voté
mais vraiment vous a pas demandé on a
demandé aux téléspectateurs ce que je
veux aussi parler de balances ton taudis
je pense que les images qu'on a revu de
marseille 9e sont très fortes et que et
que au delà de mon vote pour balance au
port et je vais expliquer pourquoi je
voulais aussi penser à un seul agrès qui
a quand même beaucoup frappé les esprits
même s'il n'a fait que l'espère des
choses vont avancer sur leurs balances
confort moi je trouve que c'est
c'est une véritable avancée c'est à dire
que ça a libéré vraiment la parole des
femmes au sens large et pas que des
pipoles même si ça a commencé par un
mouvement qui touchait le cinéma
américain
je pense que beaucoup de femmes se sont
engouffrés et ont utilisé ce hashtag
pour dénoncer des situations qui sont
totalement aberrante maintenant je mets
un juste un petit bémol c'est que on a
eu le sentiment aussi un moment donné
que ce hashtag dévier un peu de sa cible
c'est-à-dire qu'il était utilisé
réutiliser et que parfois on vous a une
sorte de chasse à des comportements qui
peuvent aujourd'hui dans le contexte qui
est le nôtre semblait totalement déplacé
de drague mais qui sont des
comportements qui ont acquis on existait
donc j'ai voté pour le hashtag du
balances ton port mais dit simplement
attention à ces dérapages et elisabeth
lévy
vous on peut dire vous êtes ah oui c'est
tout à fait contre voilà dans balances
ton porte déjà rien ne va balance c'est
un appel à la délation routine de cette
émission tous ses ballons au fond c'est
un appel à la délation
quand on dit balance son port ça veut
dire dénonçant et je ne sache pas que la
délation puisse amener à la justice je
ne sache pas non plus haut c'est ça ce
que la justice me soit rendue sur les
réseaux sociaux
et je ne sache pas qu'on obtienne la
justice en suspens dont toutes les
règles de la vieux style c'est à dire le
débat contradictoire le fait qu'on dise
aux gens de quoi ils sont accusés devant
un tribunal et non pas comme ça en les
accusant dans la rue le deuxième la
deuxième chose c'est ton port je veux
dire c'est à dire qu'il ya délation
animal isation et la syntaxe en plus
nous suggère balances ton port ça veut
dire que toutes les femmes ici présentes
ont un port à balancer ça veut dire si
elle est que ce mouvement en réalité je
préciserai de le faire avant que je suis
contre les agressions les viols le
chantage faites aux femmes
mais simplement ce mouvement a permis à
beaucoup de gens et a beaucoup de femmes
de se dire victime et surtout de
confondre la norme mais la transgression
de la norme et la norme aujourd'hui dans
nos sociétés ça n'est pas le viol ça
n'est pas l'agression qui sont condamnés
la norme c'est l'égalité ça ne veut pas
dire qu'elle est réalisée par tous mais
de la même façon il y à des vols en
france personne ne dit que la france ne
respecte pas le droit de propriété est
bien le fait qu'ils aient des viols des
meurtres de femmes est d'ailleurs aussi
des meurtres d'hommes par leur conjointe
c'est vrai ne signifie certainement pas
que la condition des femmes dans notre
pays est une suite de viols de
d'agressions de regarder autour de vous
vous ne voyez que des petits et des
faibles femmes qui sont martyrisés quand
même que ça à l'idée d'un pot à la
séance étant la libération de la parole
c'est que quand une part on nous dit la
parole s'est libérée merveilleux et
quand une parole s'est libérée dans un
autre sens on s'est fait insulter alors
la parole libérée qui marchent au pas au
pas de l'oie où tout le monde dit la
même chose
j'appelle pas ça une libération après
les faits une sortie qui ne serait pas
sorti si rihanna est excusé
qu'elle soit sortie et sur les réseaux
sociaux et oui ça ça vient ça je ne vois
pas où est le progrès ce qui m'intéresse
c'est la chaufferie s'écoulera qu'on a
pu savoir que vous avez sur quoi vous
avez su que des vous savez comment c'est
l'huma lance-t-on port n'ont pas
finalement on m'a dit à une femme on a
ça va chier qu'avait des familles a été
violée on ne savait pas normal etienne
alors vous saviez pas que des femmes
étaient violées dans un anglais jb tiré
sans mal le protocole seul traité de
porc et que ce soit le grand début d'un
mouvement parce qu'il a dit à une femme
tu as des gros seins je vais te faire
jouir mais moi je fais vraiment est ce
que vraiment
après avoir coulé le féminisme
différencier les deux ans de féminisme
on nous présente toutes les femmes comme
des petites choses qui s'effondre dès
qu'un homme les regarde
ce n'est pas la réalité des femmes dans
notre pays dans le miel des régressions
il ya des crimes
d'accord ça n'est pas le sort général
des femmes dans notre pays tous les
hommes ne sont pas des bords et toutes
les femmes prêtent pas d'argent il ya
marie la guerre merci d'être là marie
qui est étudiante vient de finir ses
partiels en architecture et en juillet
dernier elle a fini elle a publié une
vidéo qui a été vue plus de 2,4 millions
de fois on vous voit vous sur frappé au
visage par un homme après qu'il vous est
harcelée
regardez cette vidéo
alors là qu'est ce qui s'était passé là
le mari s'est en fait je rentrais chez
moi
ouais du boulot je marchais dans la rue
et du coup cet homme que j'ai croisé m'a
fait des espèces de brouiller
dégueulasse l'attiré salon des trucs
vraiment il a tiré sa langue il est
détruit la scission un petit peu qui
donne l'impression qu'on est traité
comme il reste à distance de vous ouais
il mais en fait je marche je passe juste
devant lui donc lui passe derrière moi
donc j'ai le temps de l'entendre en fait
avant derrière moi après est en fait moi
j'ai tout simplement dit ta gueule
c'était pas destiné à lui c'était
surtout destiné à moi comme une forme de
résistance mais il a entendu puisque
évidemment il est en train de le mater
et du oui s'est énervé violemment il a
attrapé un cendrier me l'a jeté dessus
moi je n'ai insultés puisque je trouve
ça absolument anormal bien sûr oui
j'étais totalement légitime de réagir et
là il est revenu en arrière et donc il
m'a frappé donc en pleine journée devant
deux terrasses remplie parce que toulon
a vu dans cette vidéo incroyable
les adn retrouvés il a été il a été il
est leur seul depuis janvier il était
condamné à six mois de prison ferme est
d'accord on voit très bien à ses
ouailles ne sont pas des mecs ça mais ça
au sort aux personnes qui sont pas
désastreux malheureusement sont pas des
mecs au sens où je l'entends tous les
jours mélangez donc quand je tournais
une femme c'est quelque chose qui arrive
tous les jours la mouche à rien parce
que vous vous ne visez pas ou alors vous
ne riez pas parce que vous vous l'avez
vécu que tu remontes le dit non non non
mais j'avais été ce sont des alibis
lisez la bauma de millions voire de
milliards de fans dans le monde entier
ça ça serait votre petite expérience
c'est que vous l'avez pas mais moi je ne
parle pas seulement de mon expérience je
dis simplement que on nous décrit
aujourd'hui la vie des femmes en france
je ne parle que de la prends comme un
enfer et vous êtes en train de décrire
mon avis on a jamais dit que c'était
offert juste marie mai à risque elle a
vécu il ya plein de familles où vivent
des admis
je dis que ça existe et ça ne devrait
pas exister le pari non mais
heureusement que toutes les femmes donc
ça de toutes les femmes ne vise pas ça
voilà nanti la première chose c'est de
pas relativiser les choses ah ouais il
vous est arrivé c'est choquant
admissibles ce type si on ne l'en tête à
l'autriche le qualifier type est un
connard de la troisième place voilà
point barre et j'aurais bien aimé être
là pour lui en était que nous au procès
on a également demandé à ce qu'ils
suivent un stage de sensibilisation
violences sexistes et sexuelles
puisqu'on estime qu' en effet la prison
ne veut pas partir on l'aider à réaliser
que ce qui fait c'est mal et c'est ça
c'est important aussi c'est que ces
personnes là elles sont nombreuses et
après le l'éducation très clairement un
problème de système qui fait que des
hommes se permet de se comporter comme
ça donc c'est important aussi d'éduquer
et de former et de sensibiliser car il
omet pourquoi j'aimerais pourquoi j'ai
mis oui et parce qu'on revenait au
mouvement ballons seront prêts au monde
alors encore à l'instant port tout à
fait conscient qu'il peut y avoir des
excès et je dirais à un moment donné une
ligne de frontière entre une drague on
peut appuyer et des phénomènes
inacceptable d'agressivité d'agression
des chutes de viol d'harcèlement
pourquoi j'ai dit oui enfin richard
excuse moi puisque les hommes c'est papa
on est là pour débattre
conscient qu'il peut y avoir des excès
cassandre d'ailleurs une maquilleuse me
disais tout à l'heure moi je suis un peu
sceptique parce qu'ils effectueraient
peut y avoir des excès c'est une femme
qui le dit il ya des femmes qui le
disent mais parce que je considère que
malgré le risque d'excès trop longtemps
les femmes se sont tus trop longtemps
les femmes ont subi trop longtemps
certaines ont même culpabiliser de
recevoir des agressions des viols en
pensant que les choses ne pourraient pas
être mis à la lumière ne serait ce que
pour ça et pour les cas qu'on a pu
aujourd'hui médiatisée de gens qui se
trouvaient intouchable
j'avais de position d'autorité de
pouvoir et qui ont agi sur des femmes de
manière scandaleuse weinstein et
d'autres parce que le type et les
réalisateurs qui peut faire tourner n'en
attendait une fille serait ce qu'une
guerre est pas trop parce qu'il peut
employer tout ça c'est inacceptable ne
serait ce que pour ces femmes-là qui
n'osaient pas et qu'ils ont ouvert écrit
aujourd'hui ont dénoncé des mecs qui
sont des
petit [ __ ] donc parce que c'était
scandaleux ce qu'elle vivait ne serait
ce que pour ça je suis en faveur de ce
même s'ils n'ont pas dénoncé que de
petits seins serait ce que vous avez
regardé et d'ailleurs dans le premier
sandra muller elle-même quant à la craie
balances ton père disait venez nous
parler des insultes et des viols
excusez-moi entre une insulte ou une
plaisanterie dont elle parlait des
plaisanteries un peu lourdingue jeu
qu'on est en train de faire derrière il
ya une entreprise de normalisation du
désert encore une fois la justice existe
dans notre pays elle nous elle ne
fonctionne pas peur à graignes allemand
mais je vous rappelle que deux tiers des
délinquants qui sont dans nos prisons le
sont pour des crimes sexuels
alors dire que la justice ne fait rien
c'est juste un monde sous menace à me
joindre à l'appel de son analyse
on a besoin du hashtag parce que la
justice à l'appel de sandra il a permis
à d'autres produits qui vous voyez un
groupement il est une attente à la
sexualité elle même face au désir
masculin dit karim ça n'autorise pas
tout c'est à dire que c'est pas parce
que ça permet effectivement d'en
attraper certains ça autorise tout moi
départ je suis pour le mouvement parce
que je me dis effectivement faut libérer
la parole et ce pour les victimes c'est
difficile de s'exprimer et sont souvent
honteuse et c est un moment j'entends le
discours de salma hayek qui dit les
hommes doivent trembler les hommes
doivent avoir peur je veux dire le
féminisme c'est pas les hommes contre
les femmes
le féminisme c'est l'égalité c'est pas
de dire que tous les hommes doivent
avoir peur tous les hommes doivent
trembler moi j'ai un véritable problème
avec ça je trouve que le message de
salma hayek a ce moment la
décrédibilisent absolument tout c'est
même insupportable c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui un homme qui me rendent
dans un ascenseur et flip quand les
bureaux se sont obligés d'être vitré
pour voir ce qui se passe dans
l'intervalle en 2000 dammarie on
développe une une société peur je ne dis
pas que ce qui était arrivé n'arrive pas
régulièrement
je dis juste que à un moment on peut pas
non plus détruire des familles parce que
ça veut pas dire toutes les femmes au
monde disent toute la vérité quand elle
balance à acheter qu'elle balance le nom
d'une personne qui est peut-être père de
famille auprès de bien que du cas la
belle juste avent je venais juste way et
auprès du jeu c'est que fut longue mais
pour une fois c'est un sujet qui me
auprès duquel elles veulent se venger
derrière il ya des enfants il ya la
famille à tout le monde ça se règle en
justice ça se règle juste
pour moi il ya un moment ça un moment où
ça doit s'arrêter twitter n'est pas le
justicier de tous et les femmes si elles
veulent vraiment que justice soit faite
et que la parole soit libéré si au
niveau des peines de justice qu'il faut
agir c'est un peu moins sur le tir alors
tu vas pas faire de la délation et
bousiller la vie de certaines personnes
parce que ça autorise tout le monde moi
je le vois sur twitter on m'accuse de
choses que j'ai jamais fait ben alors
demain je vais te l'accusé toi tu
chantes tu m'as vu le chien le côté
perdu un petit mot doit pas aller là
alors que céline dion vois pas tous
c'est à dire une christine lagarde qui
aimeraient avoir
oui déjà par rapport à je pense qu'il
faut différencier le mouvement balances
ton port c'est à dire là le fait qu'on a
libéré la parole c'est important et le
hashtag dont a parlé tout à l'heure les
salles avec levi balances ton port il
faut rappeler que sandra muller qui eric
brion on connaît l'histoire du début on
les connaît tous les deux elle sonnera
muet elle même elle a été très surprise
lorsqu'on parle l'effet de 25 ans et
elle ne s'y attendait pas du tout donc
ne s'attendait pas du tout à ce que ça
soit ça il reconnaît aussi la réponse
d'eric brillant départ au début donc il
faut différencier le ça et le mouvement
lui-même et la paire est permis de
libérer
il a permis de parler il a permis de
revoir sa vie vous pouvez avoir votre
avis mais moi je me refais ma il
m'arrivait de passer une journée ou une
journée une journée où j'avais 20 ans tu
sors de tu prends le métro
tu prends le train tu prends le rer dans
chaque wagon que tu fais il ya quelqu'un
qui se masturbe pardon j'arrive chez mon
oncle ce périmètre complètement
j'ai pris le meilleur sur vannes excusé
mal être tous les journaux mais ça
jamais vu quelqu'un fermer dans le métro
arrêtée quand même
mais ça arrive et c'est pourquoi donc ça
m'est arrivé c'est mon expérience 20 ans
je serai là vous êtes tombé sur un tram
avec koné wagon des lingots crois que ce
sera son la teub je continue je dis que
je sors je prends le métro je prends le
rer je prends le train c'est pas dans le
même wagon mais c'est pas toi même train
m chaque wagon quand je prends dans le
métro ensuite dans le rer b dans le
train pour aller à bois d'arcy
ce jour là à chaque fois il ya eu
quelqu'un qui s'est masturbé devant pas
vrai donc pour vous dire que lorsque je
suis arrivé à bois d'arcy je descends gc
m'ont donc j'en ai pour 10 minutes à
pied etc en plus dix minutes où je passe
dans une forêt où william nos menus qui
entraîne se masturber un homme la même
journée non mais je crois sur porthus
j'assure c'était pas une caméra cachée
elle apprendra sera 4 alors j'espère
vous dire ils ont beaucoup
d'associations vous avez vraiment là
alors c'est vraiment choquant mais alors
on le savait malade pas ça mais j'ai pu
voir les meilleures histoires elle est
fun cette histoire mais là je prends
l'ascenseur en une journée et je vais
vous dire qu'à partir de ce moment là je
peux comprendre qu'il ya des tables
assure encore aujourd'hui sio vivent le
calvaire
et moi je vais vous dire ça m'a choqué
je suis beyala même j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire dans cette
émission ça m'a tout ça pour dire
elisabeth ch a pas empêchés de parler si
tu perds donc tout ça pour dire que ça a
permis de libérer sa permis à des femmes
de ce normal c'est vrai a permis à des
drags de se dire je ne suis pas coupable
et que je ne suis pas coupable c'est pas
de ma faute
après en même temps je dénonce complète
ou les toutes les dérives qui a
exactement et sa geôle et dénonce parce
que justement ça occulte la vraie c'est
normal d'aider d'ériger des dérives
partout maintenant au départ le
mouvement ballons seront pas désolé il a
énormément servi et aujourd'hui il ya
plein de femmes qui se sentent soutenus
mais fois cette année l'ensemble
moi je vois pas ce qui vous permet de
dire que le bilan est positif voudrais
quand même rappeler que dans un certain
nombre d'affaires qui eux mêmes sont
aujourd'hui porter devant la justice
c'est quoi le schéma c'est un
consentement sur lequel on revient ça va
devenir extrêmement compliqué si ça
devient si vous laissiez o dia ba oui
j'ai consenti mais finalement j'ai pas
vraiment consenti parce que j'étais
aliéné parce que on est en train si vous
les deux n'auront plus la parole d'eva
eu des victimes
comment faut pas non plus banal y en a
mais il ne faut pas c'est vrai petit
garçon dit victime alors là excusez moi
je veux dire quelque chose qui va
chanter tout le monde
la parole des victimes dont on sait
qu'elles sont victimes une fois que ça a
été jugée l'éventuelle mots quand
quelqu'un vient me voir et me dit je
suis victime
eh bien je suis navré c'est quelqu'un
qui peut aussi mon tir les femmes
peuvent être aussi les rives dérivés
partout ça se trouve en train de
continuer à participer à un stéréotype
des femmes qui est vieux comme le monde
qui dit que les femmes mentent by
déraillement oui mais des gens demandent
les femmes en quête d'émotions sans nous
dire quand même à la télé et de manière
oui mouvement mais c'est la femme de 37
ans est mort lui relate hélène des
femmes quand je lis des romans vous
plaît non mais c'est très intéressant
surtout les maris ce que je trouve très
intéressant de marjah les vues donc de
ce débat c'est que tout de suite vous
avez accès sur les dérives sur les
hommes faux pas évidemment le féminisme
ce n'est pas les femmes contre les
hommes c'est les êtres humains contre un
système patriarcal qui oppresse les
cornes salma hayek 10 salles le 10 elle
dit en gros c'est doivent trembler les
deux hommes doivent avoir les palabres
jolie salma hayek serré c'est pas la
route c'est pas parce que oui mais oui
c'est pas parce que c'est mon ex qu'elle
doit ça ça n'est pas mon délire c'est
pas la question de la parole civil c'est
pas la question la parole ou des
mensonges c'est qu'on en arrive et moi
j'ai soutenu le mouvement au début parce
que pendant des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années
il ya une indifférence et même sur
complaisance envers les violences faites
aux femmes donc c'était indiscutable une
assiette on a vu quoi on a vu une dérive
ya pas s'il n'y a pas seulement ce que
la dame convient de citer caroline de
haas qui dit un homme sur trois est un
prédateur sexuel ne sais pas d'où elle
sort cette statistique
il ya maintenant le fait que quelques
heures dont une est décrétée coupable
avant le jugement si votre nom paraît
par les réseaux sociaux s'est si ni vous
pouvez attendre les jugements tant que
vous voulez et vous voyez un cas comme
woody allen par exemple qui ils m'ont ce
réalisateur qui ne peut plus sortir un
film parce qu'ils ont brouillé dans une
histoire avec sa belle-fille le climat
fait que les producteurs ne veulent même
plus sortir mais ce que le cavaliere a
été reconnue par aucun lien pas de
jugement il n'y a pas de jugement en
fait il n'y a pas de mise en accusation
officielle simplement le climat fait qu
on dit faut le prendre dans sa naissance
et l'origine est indiscutable je trouve
que ça dérape
attendez attendez surtout cette soupe et
s'il vous plaît pas tout seul moi
j'aurais juste dire un truc c'est ce
qu'on dit mais il ya des franchement il
ya des dérives partout d'autres euros
c'est normal qu'ils aient des pieds d
day mais le mouvement à la base on est
tous d'accord
aliot sont d'ailleurs pour dire ça à
libérer la parole des femmes moi quand
je vois ça je suis désolé voilà c'est ça
c'est inadmissible et demi celle des
immigrés des mecs aussi à galets m'ont
dit la vérité
est-ce que vous avez déjà été herbe dont
vous avez fait beaucoup
vous êtes très mignonne vous êtes très
sympathique est-ce que vous avez déjà
été confronté à ce qu'on appelle même
des rôles où des mecs qui sont lourds
qui vous soulevez à l'homme il faut
faire disparaître les rôles ou acier non
mais leur meilleur mais ça peut être
pour sa potiche au jour le jour mais
avoir un gros loup qui tu saoules la
tête l'autrichien dans la visionner il
faut souligner les faits quand même
vertueux et salvateur qu'a eu ce
mouvement à son origine
il a permis à plein de femmes qui se
taisaient de se sentir soutenu de
cendres est assez forte et puissante
pour prendre la parole et dire les
traumatismes killer qui leur sont
arrivés si je n'étais pas conscient
granulaire dit aussi voilà un petit
chaussée il ya des petites choses aussi
du quotidien qui peuvent troubler demain
ici tous les jours au bureau c'est un
étudiant est petit et qui vous regardent
et qui boudent sous les quais sera long
mais non moins c'est pire des parts il
fallait quand même y avoir une confusion
générale qui bat de shiva et de ses
thèmes dont le ya quand même on confond
tout c'est à dire on mélange est écouté
peut-être que les blagues ne s'est pas
agréable un poste mais toutes les femmes
rencontrent à un moment ou un autre des
expressions c'est unir à quatre roues
est leur manque de désir n'hésite pas à
vous depuis rien d importer agace saga
est ce que vous avez déjà qu'ils étaient
confrontés vous une généralité parfaite
et derrag après avoir venir sur marie
est-ce que ce que vous avez déjà été
confronté vous a détruit voilà tous les
jours mais évidemment mais met donc sans
s'ennuyer ce qu'a apporté ce mouvement
c'est vrai qu' on est tombé dans une
spirale assez nauséabondes et là je
rejoins quand même un petit peu
elisabeth lévy sait que moi de carrément
des journalismes appelé en me demandant
marselan de dénoncer des mecs de mon
entourage professionnel
mais bon c'est fort c'est forcément que
taiwo a retenu vous autres ou autres
seraient non vous at-on jamais eu
d'ambiguïté bien sûr il a déjà demandé
pourquoi comme s'ils s'étaient perdus
comme si j'allais joli monde si j'avais
les achats des voleurs et du non tout va
très bien et chante j'observe tous poils
pour vous demandera pas je suis trop
sauvage les ans en faveur des verts
j'avais raconté effectivement dans un
escalator de me retrouver dans un
escalator complètement vide avec un type
qui vient se mettre dans sur la marche
juste derrière eh bien on descendait il
était dans le métro etc et non en fait
on des santés l'escalator qui était vide
donc au moment où il s'est prêté à ce
genre d'agissements yade et les vigiles
en bas j'ai crié que c'était un frotteur
donc les comptes il s'est fait cueillir
en bas par l'homme ce n'est pas mal non
plus pas et prend forcément les réseaux
sociaux j'irai sur les réseaux sociaux
dénoncé avec un hashtag non je le ferai
pas parce qu'on peut distinguer
distinguer effectivement le fait que la
présomption d'innocence
sur cet axe sur ses affaires comme sur
toutes les affaires de même on jeudi
eric revel et m pédophiles et sur les
réseaux sociaux de nommer alors il avait
rejoué
[Rires]
tout à fait je m'arrête excuse moi mais
c'est elle est tombée celle où tu dis
souvent des tubes qu'il est décrété il
avait été vite une bauloise il aimait
vous dirai ce que je sais pas parce que
que des crêpes chaudes sur twitter qui
est une accusation vous savez quoi faire
une vérité à la fin je me dis c'est un
support c'est ça que je veux dire nous
faisons de la course
non il ya une justice ainsi que doivent
statuer donc le nouveau membre a permis
de dénoncer des choses mais moi quand
ayez une des nos sérieuses sur twitter
je la prends pas pour argent comptant
bien sûr et vous avez raison
à dire ma jambe papier ou sur la norme
ieee mary mary mary la guerre mary chain
ce que je voulais dire marie j'aimerais
bien qu'elle nous dise quelle heure nous
dire parce qu'on va clôturer et on va
passer à l'intervenant de la mer si ce
qu'un type est difficile de s'exprimer
face à madame lévy qui veut absolument
imposer son point de vue complètement
dépassé il faut laisser la place aux
jeunes générations qui ont peut-être les
nombreuses stars c'est un argument genre
et je suis trop il a pas dit vous êtes
humaine si vous êtes une voleuse d'or
[Applaudissements]
mais ça correspond à une vérité c'est
qu'il ya quand même une rupture entre
les générations
si vous étiez jeune vous dire une chose
à les images sévères intéressant fait le
plat proches que vous avez face à ce
mouvement qui est énormément tourné vers
le côté de la délation et les dérives
alors oui certes on entend alors des
ministres je suis total aux jeux ne peut
pas être pour la délation public en un
système de juste de justice il faut lui
faire confiance
le problème c'est que en effet la
justice trop souvent laisse tomber les
femmes et ça je trouve ça assez triste
de devoir aller jusqu'à fait une
délation un public mais ça peut aussi
soulevé les questions de peut-être piano
de 6 à m'améliorer mais en général du
coe
ce que je trouve dommage c'est justement
de déplacer le débat alors que pour moi
le débat c'est toutes ces millions de
femmes qui ont parlé et qui ont
légitimiser aussi la parole des
prochaines femmes qui vont parler de
leur agression que ces salons avant tout
c'est montrer à quel point c'est un
phénomène s'est pas il s'agit pas
d'attaqués lui lui c'est surtout autour
des femmes qui enfin on peut s'exprimer
et de montrer l'ampleur
et puis bon je suis non mais c'est vrai
que c'est vrai que voilà moi mon choix
ça pour moi c'est ça c'est vraiment moi
restera donc voila moi le classe que
vous arrivez avec ballon ce sont pendant
que vous étiez au bon endroit
elles ont une libération j'ai appris à
son ex mari trop courts les chercheurs
aujourd'hui on nous écoute beaucoup
mieux parce que en effet jamais seul
c'est ça c'est bien et c'est beau et je
trouve que c'est trop lente et cette
solidarité entre femmes elle est
importante oui après évidemment les
délations tout ça oui mais je veux dire
ça concerne quand même un tout petit
pourcentage de ce qui a été dit sur
twitter et dans la bouffe la caf qui est
bref ce n'est pas vrai alors non mais il
s'agit pas d'embêter les gens à manille
s'agit pas de durée il s'agit de montrer
en fait que qu'il ya plein de femmes sur
une histoire c'est pas cette histoire
c'est que montrer qu'on est toutes
concernées qu'on a tout vécu des choses
alors moi je suis assez d'accord avec
vous après comme comme quand vous dites
on peut pas savoir qui ment qui n'ont
pas mais mine de rien ça a libéré la
parole il écoute exactement il écoute
donc cette voie là alors il va voir ce
qu'on pense
les téléspectateurs à duda correct oui à
52% non à 48 points c'est plus équilibré
qu'ici sur le plateau c'est